when people were asked would you want to
date this person for women it mattered
they would actually prefer to date the
dorky looking guy in the wall street
clothes to the handsome guy who's
working at burger king for men they
prefer the good-looking woman who worked
for burger king to the less attractive
woman who was dressed to the nines
doug you just mentioned that you'd taken
two months away from working
and this is one of your first days back
talk to me about
what it feels like to take such a long
break when you're used to doing so much
work do you ever get the
compulsion to go and do stuff do you get
antsy about the fact that you're not
working
yes i
i like having a bit of fun but uh
there's only so much of it i can take i
actually feel better i feel better when
i'm being productive in some way
although my work is
you know uh
writing books and being a college
professor and talking to students it's a
it's a pretty cushy job and uh
you know it's it it's
in some ways
more pleasant than actually being on
vacation although being on vacation was
fun
what do you think that says adaptively
about humans the fact that you can take
more pleasure from doing work than from
leisure
what do you think dave
well i mean i think a lot of it is
the affiliation factor right i i know
for me one of the things i like about
work is
the people i work with um and getting to
see them
and uh
and that feeling of
sort of purpose right that it's like i
think we are sort of designed to want to
contribute
to
those around us and uh
you know
hopefully if
someone is in a job that they like
then they'll feel like oh i'm working
with a group of people to
improve the world for
people so i think
yeah i think that's
that's i like dave's answer because i
wouldn't have pointed to affiliation
right away i would have thought of
status in terms of our little our
hierarchy of motives uh
but
i like what dave is saying because it
strikes me that in the ancestral
environment if you took two months off
uh the people in your group might have
started to get a little annoyed at you
you know what are you going to start to
catch some fish
you know uh and so
you know i i like the fact that they've
connected to people because it does uh
i especially like i do like that as well
in fact the first thing i i did after
having this an interview this morning is
i went to a meeting and our graduate
students were there and
my uh
co-author on a number of papers steve
newberg was there and it did feel good
felt good to be doing something with the
group
uh and so
i guess it i guess we're sort of wired
up to connect those two things
you just mentioned about your new
pyramid of human motives
why do we need a new one or what's
unique or interesting about this one
so
two things one is that
uh
when maslow
made his hierarchy he didn't make that
pyramid that wasn't even a hierarchy
right
yeah well no it was a hierarchy he did
actually say that there were uh
there were a set of goals he was arguing
against behaviorists the behavior is
thought that everything we do
can boil down to satisfying thirst and
hunger even our social motives the
behaviorists argued were
connected to
secondary reinforcement we come to like
people because our mother nursed us
and uh maslow was a student of harry
harlow who did those classical studies
with the mo the baby monkeys that were
separated from their moms and so forth
and harlow was arguing against the
behaviorists that no we have
we
at least primates have other social
motives and maslow just made a more
complicated model and argued that
developmentally
first we have to just get fed and get
you know get warm
but then we get stranger anxiety we have
to protect ourselves
and then we want to make friends and
then we want to steam which is what we
would call status so we agree with him
up to that point
where we disagree with maslow was that
he thought then we moved to non-social
things we move above that we want to go
off and play the guitar by ourselves or
write poetry just for our own intrinsic
satisfaction
and from an evolutionary perspective
it seems extremely unlikely that we
would be designed that we got here
because our ancestors once they had
managed to solve those lower motives
went off and you know beat on the beat
on a log just for their own
entertainment if they beat on a log it
was probably to entertain the other
members of their groups so that they
could
achieve
you know acceptance
and respect and
find mates
and ma the other thing that maslow
skipped out on completely was the
importance of mating he was an
evolutionary psychologist before the
modern day and he didn't think about
the fact that in some sense organisms
are all designed to reproduce and so at
the the top of our pyramid is not
self-actualization
it's sort of what unfolds
developmentally first after you've
gotten some respect you find a mate
after you find that mate you need to
keep the mate and then if you have
offspring you need to care for your
family uh and even if you don't have
offspring we're probably motivated to
care for our cousins and the other
people in our group and so we're not
arguing in some sense that it's ideal
that it that you're we all
in the same sense that
self-actualization painting a beautiful
painting is somehow intrinsically
satisfying what we're arguing is that is
that
that's the natural course of things as
to is to move on
to you know to reproduction maslow had
the only time you talked about sex was
as a lower physiological need
and so on that model you could just
masturbate and then be done with it and
then you can move on to playing the
guitar you know
but
we
we disagree with that part of it um
yeah it seems
it seems to me that um
most people when you ask them about the
most meaningful stuff that they do in
their lives they talk about rearing
children
and it seems as well i don't know
whether you guys would agree with this
but
we are grandchildren optimizers
is the nicest summary of what humans are
kind of here to do
that i've thought of it's like you you
need to have some kids then you need to
make sure that those kids have some kids
and after that point you're kind of
sweet after that point you can you can
pretty much just let everything go
but the great grandkids are on their own
yeah oh i mean there is so your lab did
some research on that right like
actually asking people what gave them
meaning and it was it was split right
into there was parenting and then there
was also
just general taking care of
family that included also like brothers
and sisters and things like that so
um so i guess you you also have to look
out for like your nieces and nephews as
well
so so
it's actually even a little more comfy
in that we ask people three kinds so
there's three ways you can define
well-being one of them is just
hedonic well-being i feel good there's
more rewards in my life than punishments
in my life
and then there's what they call
eudemonic well-being which is a fancy
way of saying meaning in life okay and
then the third is self-actualization
which is a way of saying fulfilling your
highest potential
so what we did in our lab
some research with jamie krems uh who's
at uh oklahoma state and becca neal
who's the university of toronto now
we
asked people about each of those things
what would you be doing right now
if you were
for if you were getting meaning in life
okay what would be the thing that would
produce the most meaning in your life
and that's what the thing dave was
referring to that's when they said i'd
be caring for my family or i'd be
hanging with my friends for the for the
most part when we asked about
self-actualization
what would you be doing if you were
achieving your highest potential
then they talked about things like you
know
writing a book or uh you know managing a
business and they connected that with
status and also with affiliation
and then the one of hedonic well-being
what would i be doing if i wanted to
just feel good
their affiliation still affiliation
comes in across the board you know uh
but uh then sex became more you know
finding a mate
rose up especially for males uh they
would feel good
they'd feel you know hedonic
satisfaction
if they were in a romantic situation uh
but it's funny that those other kinds of
well-being are those they're all
connected to different motives did you
look at the mappiness study that
had a ton of data done on it
the what study mappiness
nappiness i i don't know it no okay
about it so this was a study done by a
bunch of researchers who were using
mobile phones to pop up and ask people
what they were doing at that point and
their subjective rating and how happy
this yes uh and then seth stevens
davidowitz who's a data scientist has
just released a new book called don't
trust your gut and in that he looks
through a bunch of this stuff and then
lays it out in this really easy table
and the number one thing plus 20 in
terms of happiness the most happy thing
that people are doing is having sex now
what i couldn't
i couldn't help thinking about the fact
that the only way that that's been able
to work is if someone's paused having
sex to check the phone note down that
they were doing it and then rate the
subjective level of happiness um
but yeah i mean this this is an
interesting distinction i think between
uh dan gilbert and daniel kahneman
gilbert was talking about the fact that
you know lying on a lilo for the rest of
your life drinking cocktails might be a
way to spend a life well lived because
each individual interval of time is
something that's been pleasurable
whereas kahneman i think retrospectively
would say a good life is one that in
retrospect you're glad you lived it had
meaning it had purpose it made you feel
retrospectively like something is
worthwhile and i've come to believe my
bro science is that that tends toward
people that are more introspective and
retrospective versus people that are a
little bit more impulsive that really
the um balance that you have between
those two things whether you lean more
towards uh hedonic pleasure or sort of
you dymonic pleasure is mostly because
okay what what what do you think about
when you think about the things that you
value in yourself do you value you know
just time with friends free flowing and
being easy or do you like hard things
that you're contributing to over a
longer period of time
yeah no i like you're raising an
interesting question i think you know uh
about individual differences
in those in those uh and we actually
have a scale of that measures in becca
neil i mentioned before we developed a
scale with us that uh looks at
uh the extent to which i am someone who
is currently concerned with each of
those motives we talked about finding
mates or finding friends or you know
protecting myself from the bad guys
uh but
what you're suggesting is interesting
that those different kinds of well-being
you know what gives me those might vary
as a function of
you know who i am and maybe what i'm
what my major goal in life is right now
yeah it could also i imagine
have to do with sort of situational
factors if you have kids right you might
be like thinking more like no no i need
a meaningful life because that might tie
into
also
providing for those kids and things like
that whereas if you are younger or you
don't have kids and you're like no at
the people around me are taken care of
then you might opt for just you know
reading a book in the shade so i could
see how those could change throughout
the life history as well given the fact
that the modern world's more comfortable
for humans why do you think it is then
that a lot of human problems seem even
more difficult to solve today
what's your take on that dave
oh i mean there's a bunch of things i
mean well one is the sort of mismatch
right of between our
instincts in the modern world um and
then a big one is we also have
with technology a lot of sort of things
that will remind us we have technology
that's optimized
to prime all of these motives at once
right you're gonna sort of
you're gonna see pictures of attractive
people that your brain will think of as
potential mates you're gonna see news
about threats you're going to see you
know
updates from your friends and you can
get all of these things
in a matter of
seconds or minutes right if you're on
your phone and so
um it's
pretty overwhelming right to try to to
try to like in the ancestral world you
can sort of focus on one thing at a time
right you're if you're going out to get
food
you might not even see any potential
mates um you might have a few friends
with you who are also there to get food
um
but these days i think
we've got to do everything at once right
and we've got to compete in our minds
with
if you want to compete with status
you're now competing with elon musk as
opposed to just your actual next door
neighbor right and same thing you know
you see this with um with
girls with instagrams they have body
image issues right they're competing
with like
these with models all the time um and
they're just that's intermixed with
their friend feed and so i think the
the hierarchies have gotten a lot higher
like now we're now we're competing with
what seven billion people as opposed to
ten um and so
i think i think those all combined to
make uh
a pretty stressful
pretty stressful situation
so
is there a sense going back to maslow's
hierarchy of needs but you could map it
on to yours i guess as well is there a
sense that because so much of the bottom
area of the pyramid the immediate
physiological needs the safety the
security and stuff like that that that's
been filled it is an existential crisis
a luxurious position to be in basically
is it only in a world that's got so many
of those safety features already filled
in that you have the opportunity to
think what am i doing with my life what
should i be doing with my life how could
i contribute better to my sense of
well-being am i really actualizing my
potential here
that's so that's interesting
i personally am not beyond
worrying about those uh those base
motives you know living in arizona i'm
always like reading about our water
levels and our drought and things like
that um
so
i mean i
i don't know i think a lot of people are
still worried about these um they're
they're
i don't
i know that we no longer have food
insecurity the way our ancestors did but
you know health is still a major concern
for a lot of people um and
so i'm not sure i'm not sure we're at
the point where we're sort of
mindfully thinking about our
higher motives
so i think we just have them stacked on
there so i wonder if an existential
crisis is just a
it's a an attribution for something else
it means
maybe i'm
you know i'm not achieving the goal that
i really want to achieve now i'm not
finding a satisfying relationship or i'm
not you know doing a satisfactory job
taking care of my kids or
uh not getting respect
on the job and then i
i attribute that to something higher
because i've got a college degree and so
i think ah well i can't just be uh some
sap who's screwing up uh what's really
happening is i'm concerned with the
whole meaning of existence
i see okay so it's it's uh loneliness
masquerading as a philosophical treatise
maybe maybe yeah i i could see it being
loneliness and then also sort of
status frustration you know if you look
at people online i think that i think
these days in the modern era
there's
i mean there's all these sort of
phenomenon of people who are like
they don't have friends right they're
staying in their room but they're
they're eating they're surviving and so
there's this there's become this big
jump where it's like okay
i'm surviving but
to get to that next level to actually
contribute to give my
existence meaning to other people
seems
too hard
um and and so that could be part of what
is
leading to
existential crises perhaps talk to me
about the relationship between
ancient fears and desires with modern
dangers and opportunities then
so you i mean you've mentioned the
concept of mismatch you know that in
some sense
we're designed to live in a in a small
village you know people debate about
what was the ancestral environment
actually like
and
well there were lots of different
ancestral environments but they were
different from the modern one in certain
recurring ways they did involve being
around your kin okay even when i was a
kid growing up in a little urban village
in new york i had my grandmother and my
aunts they all lived in nearby
apartments you know and now we spread
out so you know
widely
that we're when we can be surrounded by
strangers and our ancestors were were
not surrounded by strangers unless they
were about to die okay um
and that is i think that's that's one of
the biggest mismatches and that accounts
for
many of these problems the other kinds
of well there's mismatches of different
sort at every level so the at the low
level the one about survival uh
we
you know
we certainly don't have to worry about
getting food okay i mean as and during
my travels one of the things i was
shocked at is that i could buy
wood-fired pizza and find a fine
restaurant with local
tasty wines everywhere in the middle of
you know in places i would have
considered the middle of nowhere there's
this fabulous food and every little
convenience store has ben and jerry's
ice cream everywhere you go i could get
some really delicious ice cream i could
get a six pack of
of india pale
uh can i can i just say one thing though
but but this is all contingent on having
money right and this this one of the
other ways that the modern world
is different you had mentioned that you
weren't likely to get
you weren't likely to be around
strangers unless you were about to get
killed there's also this thing of you
weren't likely to get killed unless you
were around strangers like you're the
people around you would help you out but
nowadays when we're traveling all over
the place
if you run out of money right which you
know for somebody who is like
has a good
solid bank account may not be a risk but
for a lot of people
you're in the middle of nowhere and you
run out of money
the risks are really high right you if
you try to steal food you're gonna go to
jail like you're not going to somebody
is not going to be as forgiving as if
you borrow food from a relative and so
that's interesting dave because actually
you know
despite having a reasonable bank account
i lived petrified of losing my wallet
because if i was in banff alberta
beautiful place but i didn't have a
wallet i would have been screwed okay
because i kept thinking that what would
i do what would i do for food what if
somebody steals my wallet
so one of my friends a couple of years
ago we went on a stag due to barcelona
actually no sorry it was the wedding the
stag dude was wild but the wedding was
even worse so we went to a wedding uh in
barcelona and i don't know what you know
but barcelona is the robbery capital of
europe yes i've been warned when i went
to barcelona unbelievably pocket zipped
sophisticated these kids that can do
lionel messi style tricks with a
football will come over and accidentally
bump into you and before you know it
they've dribbled the ball between your
legs but they've also taken your car
keys too so we went to this thing one of
the guys came back anyway he
one of the lads had a bit too much to
drink he doesn't usually drink he fell
asleep in barcelona train station woke
up the next morning to find out that his
phone his wallet and his shoes had been
stolen his shoes had been stolen from
him uh and then he was trudging around
but he was a crossfit coach so the thing
that he went back to this is a point
where you basically don't have any of
the
um
no trust required transactional proofs
of status or legitimacy which is what
paper paper money could be seen as right
none of that existed but he's a crossfit
coach so he walked into a crossfit gym
he knew that there was a crossfit gym
somewhere in barcelona walked into a
crossfit gym and said hey guys i know
that i look like i've walked a hole in
my socks i'm dressed for a wedding that
was yesterday no phone no money no shoes
however if you go on instagram you'll
see that i'm that guy and i'm that guy
that you've probably seen coaching some
of your favorite athletes so what he did
was he gravitated toward the closest
thing that he could find to kin
that's interesting yeah i like that
that's a great story
i saw um a stat from your book that said
more people die from obesity than
starvation now according to the u.n
yeah yeah that was that was a
fascinating thing to run across as we
were preparing that was wild yeah
it is oh and that's a good example of of
mismatch because even dave even despite
the fact that we do worry about
even if we're poor now we have enough
money that we can afford twinkies and
other you know unhealthy foods and so i
i was amazed that i got a as i got away
from the less wealthy parts of you know
canada and into the sticks i would see
more obesity there it's almost like the
it's almost now it now
uh
wealthy people i think are thinner i i
don't know if that statistically
bears out but i feel like it does it
does hold when i would the uh
how would you say the threshold for
having enough money to in order to be
able to make yourself fat is actually
pretty low you don't very much you don't
need a lot of us i think in order to be
able to make yourself fun but actually
you need more money to buy uh organic
vegetables and fruits you know like
blueberries cost more money than a you
know
a a similar number of calories
uh and a loaf of you know cheap bread or
uh and uh some hostess twinkies which i
don't know if you know what hostess
twinkies are but they're the
they're the classical fast food of my
generation they're
in the empty calories as they say is it
true that they're supposed to be able to
survive a nuclear apocalypse and they
basically never go off
apparently oh so
we haven't tested it but yeah um i know
that you guys looked at uh suicide here
as well have you ever seen any data
around how many people committed suicide
ancestrally or how common it was
i i have i actually thought of that do
you have you come across that dave i
mean i know that there are you know you
can think about like um
samurai sort of like
there are traditional societies where
suicides were
were
part of a thing you would do if you
brought shame to your tribe so it's it's
not unheard of um i don't know that we
have i mean i certainly don't know of
statistics the way we have modern
statistics to compare
um
i mean i think there were also
there were a lot more ways to
risk your life
rather than just
kill yourself right if things aren't
going well you could be into the punch
by in the environment yes
yeah yeah you can go out and and this is
i think one of the things we sort of
talk about is this idea that
suicide might actually that that desire
or that lack of desire for
self-preservation might come from this
place of you've got your sort of basic
needs met but you're not meeting those
social needs right and so it might
actually be your brain's way of saying
all right go take some risks it's time
to you know it's time to go out there
and
maybe get yourself eaten by a lion or
whatever but maybe you'll find a really
cool
oasis you know and so so that is
one of the one of the possibilities
we've discussed is that this that really
what people are
they're feeling like
these other meat needs are not being met
and they're sort of overvaluing survival
a little bit so you know what's cool
about what you're saying dave is that
like
i think it's there's no doubt that
people acted what we call suicidal
you know uh in the answer they might not
have actually gone out and and you know
conscious they well they couldn't have
taken pills they could have thrown
themselves off a cliff but they could
certainly have gone out and
screamed at a member of another tribe
and gotten themselves killed or ended up
looking good if they won the fight you
know uh
as we were driving through montana dave
i know dave was born in montana uh and
as we were driving through i got the
audio tape of of a book called the river
runs through it which is a very
beautiful book it's a sort of poetic
depiction of this relationship between a
guy and his younger brother and if you
haven't ever read it chris it's one of
the most beautifully written english
books in english literature uh
and it was recommended to me by the
department chair of the university of
chicago who said he had a colleague who
never did anything his whole life and
they thought maybe we shouldn't have
given him tenure and then he wrote this
book
and this guy said this old professor
said it should have won the pulitzer
prize except that it came out the year
of roots but it's a beautiful depiction
and i remember there's a beautiful
depiction of the nature and of fly
fishing but a lot of it involves these
are guys in the 1930s going out into
bars getting plastered drunk out of
their mind uh and getting into fist
fights and you know going out into the
wilderness and doing crazy [ __ ] you know
uh and you know the brother who ends up
dead in the end uh does have a what we
would call a suicidal tendency to it
isn't like he's thinking of ending his
own life purposefully but he's certainly
putting himself in situations where he's
either going to look really good or he's
going to die
you know and it's a true story in fact
in the end he gets murdered by some
people who he probably pissed off
well i mean the equivalent ancestrally
it wouldn't have been death by enemies
or death by cop it might have been death
by lion or something
death by goring from some exactly
it could be death by
you know fighting other
tribes it could also be death by
challenging people in your tribe you
know um and so although that probably
would have been less likely to end in
actual death death but um but yeah so
death by cop that's a nice association
chris when you say that because i
actually think that that's a good that's
a nice way of capturing what i was just
talking about i think that a death by
cop is probably some
macho guy there's probably an out of a
lot of women who die by cop but it's
probably a lot of young guys with a lot
of testosterone
that decide they're going to show people
how tough they are um
that's the thing that you see as well
right that uh over time testosterone
decreases with a decrease in
testosterone less risk-taking behavior
when men get into relationships
testosterone drops when they get married
it drops when they have kids it drops
again because the guy that continues to
take tons of risks and gets death by
lion is of little use to the three
children that he's just brought into the
world or the wife that's waiting back at
the cave for him
right yeah
the math the math changes for what so
this like going back to this sort of
like pyramid of motives like this is
part of why i
sort of always i'm like a little
hesitant to even call it a pyramid
because it's like you've got you know
protection friendship
um needs mating taking care of kin
that math is constantly changing right
you have kids and then suddenly
it makes
less sense for you to run out and
go do something super risky
when instead if there's a way for you to
just sort of
find a little bit a little bit of food
here and a little bit of food there and
keep your kids alive you know um so
[Music]
and our our physiology changes to sort
of accommodate that like like these
testosterone level drops so yeah
how do you know that
go ahead i was just gonna refer to the
there's a study that you may know chris
by uh martin daley and margot wilson
they did a paper on the young male
syndrome uh and it was about
uh it was about the
tendency to uh like die in homicidal
conflicts and what they found is that in
fact it's very high for young guys of
mating age
and
you know and in subsequent research they
found it's especially guys in situations
of desperation
okay like upper middle class kids who
went to college they don't go out and do
this kind of thing but if you don't have
any other way to prove
that you're you know that you're you've
got something special about you then you
take these desperate acts uh and so in
fact it fits with all of what we've been
talking about that the that it's young
desperate men
that are in fact we talk about in the
book they're the people that you want to
watch out for um
and if you're one of them you kind of
want to watch out for yourself
just how violent are humans
evolutionarily
i compared to what like compared to how
we are now yeah
oh i mean
i think now is the most peaceful time
pretty much in human history right um
and like
what we have we have statistics of the
murder rates of do you know those off
the top dad well so there's this big
debate because some people
you know like to argue oh no it was
you know that it's exaggerated uh but i
talked to kim hill who's one of the
world's prominent anthropologists who's
done studies of like the aceh uh
and
uh
what he found in one of his studies of
us of a south american group is the
homicide rate was like 40 50 and then
people came in and said oh no that's
only because they got killed by the
spanish agricultural people around
but but i went and re-looked at his data
when you took out the murders by the
by the non-native groups
it was still a 25 or 30 homicide rate
and so that's a high and but even
amongst the eskimos and the bushmen
stephen pinker talks about this in a
couple of his books but you know
particularly the one the better angels
of our nature where he compares all of
the known data on violence and you know
in hunter-gatherer groups
and the least violent hunter-gatherer
groups the bushmen and another group
whose name i'm forgetting their homicide
rates were about similar to the city of
new orleans which is the most violent
city
in the united states which is the most
violent uh
developed country
uh in the world and so
it was yeah it was dangerous
why is it then
that we feel so unsafe day to day
if the world is objectively safer than
ever before
i'll let you take that
well part of it is i mean it's
it's
advantageous to feel unsafe right it's
it there's a
advantage to just looking for threats
into being
hyper aware of threats and
there hasn't been enough time
evolutionarily for that to go away right
because you don't want to miss a threat
um and
uh and then
beyond that there are these sort of
because we
don't want to miss a threat
you know i think you can certainly see
with
news and things like that there there
are
things that
command that attention uh for
profit or for views or whatever and so
we still
we hear about
probably more well certainly more
murders because we hear about more
murders than our ancestors would hear
about people right so we're constantly
aware of things like you know like i
mean the war in the ukraine which is a
very serious thing but it's it's also
very far from me right now but i'm
paying attention to it right because i
want to know what's happening and so
i think
so that there's that interplay between
our evolved mechanism and the technology
that
taps into that so let me just back to
what the concept of mismatch
that
you know we're designed to look for
threats in a world where there aren't
that many people and even though there
were homicides they weren't every day
but the the news media capitalized we
had that powerful motive that dave was
just referring to i want to know if
there's a threat and so if i'm even the
new york times you know which is the
sort of the liberal media or if i'm fox
news which is the more conservative
media in the u.s so it's like they're
both going to want to give us some bad
news they're going to want to talk about
threats why because
we want to know about it we you know we
may say oh gee why don't they put more
good news we don't click on the good
news links we click on the ukraine we
click on there was a murder in chicago
you know we you know it's like i know
about murders
in africa you know and it's like
we would have never known about murders
in the in the you know in distant places
so it seems like holy crap what a
dangerous world we live in but now i ask
the question of you know well it might
be different from you chris but you know
i doubt it uh
do i know anybody who was murdered
i do not know a single person i grew up
in new york city around lots of people
and i knew i know more people than most
of my ancestors ever knew i don't know
any i didn't know people who went to war
okay um but i don't know uh anyone who
was like murdered in a kind of violent
you know urban or suburban do you know
anybody who was murdered either one of
you guys no not me
uh i had my my neighbor's brother was
murdered uh i didn't know him personally
but that's that's the closest i could
i could think of oh so thinking about
the fact that we've got this
evolutionary mismatch and uh how would
you say
vestigial negativity bias perhaps that
carries over from our ancestral past i'm
sure that you guys must have thought
about what happens in future if humans
continue if we were able to
keep around about 2022-ish
as the level of environment that we're
going to be in for the next
100 000 years
what sort of changes do you think we
would see to the human psyche have you
got any idea about what would be
adaptive obviously the problem that we
have and the reason i need to keep us at
2022 is that technology's going to move
more quickly than our evolution can
catch up with it but if we were to hold
ourselves where we're at now would that
would the negativity bias come down
would there be other changes that you
might expect to see
i i would think you probably would that
there probably would be because i
imagine it takes resources
to
i mean it definitely takes resources to
be on alert right and so
being less nervous
would have
i think it would have enough of a
evolutionary benefit this is not really
a thing that we've ever i think
discussed before um but yeah just
thinking about it right now
i mean
we would
[Music]
yeah we would we would redirect that
part of our brain to figuring out how to
get it more likes um and how to how to
program better probably like it is it is
possible we'll use the technology i
actually don't think there's going to be
enough of a selection pressure
uh
against good enough because technology
changes so quickly but i do think we
could use the technology i mean dave you
and i have talked about this developing
apps for example
that you know that are much much more
effective at preventing us from spending
too much screen time you know uh and
i know that i personally will turn off
my new york times they used to give me
you know they would give me uh
daily reminders of the news okay and
political parties who asking for my
money will give me daily reminders of
all the dangerous stuff that the other
side is doing out there and what i do is
i close those apps i i you know i
disconnect from them
but i think in the future
that they're maybe we'll be able to get
some executive control you know sort of
ia working where i can say how much of
this [ __ ] do i want to hear and i don't
want to hear about it more than once a
week uh and maybe you guys are younger
and you you may have a different opinion
but do you think we there might be a
market for that kind of technology and i
in my opinion i think we're going to
look back hoping i hope this is the case
that people in about 50 to 100 years are
going to look back on what we do with
technology now or more accurately what
technology does to us in the same way as
when we can generate our own meat in a
lab people are going to look at factory
farms i think they're going to see it as
a complete aberration what on earth were
they doing look at all of this wasted
time and focus and attention look what
they did to young girls and their body
image look at the levels of anxiety and
self-harm and all of these perverse
incentives that we had i wonder as well
because
one of the constraints that you had
around psychopathy and machiavellianism
was the fact that your group was so
small that you could only get away with
a small number of those people per group
i also found out
that
psychopathy is actually adaptive on a
group level but not necessarily on an
individual level because if you're a
viking tribe it's pretty useful for you
to have a few psychopaths that you can
send over to lindisfarne to go and suck
it kill everybody and come back with a
ton of gold but you don't want too many
so that it actually makes the group
unstable my thinking being that because
we're no longer as
uh at the mercy
or as visible uh and people can bounce
around you know the snake oil salesman
can go from town to town now um that you
may have
more
incentives more adaptive uh pressures
that allow people to take advantage of
machiavellian or or psychopathic tracks
so the world is certainly set up you
know we talk about this in the book even
the automobile right does allow for
it makes machiavellian
strategies more effective right um and
so actually just to tie this real
quickly back to what you were just
asking about how we would evolve
i could see counter measures to those
sorts of things counter measures to
cheater detection
like becoming more
more salient you know like and also um
we've been talking about this sort of i
think from the perspective of guys being
worried about other guys i think
for women there's still a lot of the
same sort of
threats that they faced threats of sort
of
you know pregnancy unwanted pregnancy
and things like this
those might be getting
worse because of some of this technology
um and so
those sorts of things i feel like those
counter measures are going to we're
going to become more and more
aware of
wait is this person
is this person going to
[Music]
rip me off you know like not necessarily
they're going to beat me up but they're
going to
convince me to
engage in a
in a pyramid scheme or something like
this or you know is this person who is
approaching me as a potential mate
are they
really trustworthy so i think those
sorts of risks are
possibly even higher than they've ever
been but i think that's more like
cultural evolution than biological
evolution in some sense so i know
growing up in new york city
i learned
not to trust strangers in a way that you
know my mother-in-law who grew up in a
little town in delaware you know when
she moved out to arizona uh she would
leave her doors unlocked she would leave
her keys in her car you know and you
know one of my of my cars got stolen
from her parking lot you know uh
but for me
i it was very easy for me to to be
suspicious because i'd grown up around
strangers and so
some of it might simply be that we
you know we pick it up
we
basically use
those old mechanisms and just
set them to a lower threshold than
uh than we would have and
that may continue what did you learn
about how friendships work
in the in the book yeah okay yes uh
so
well i i'm gonna just jump in here
because i think one of the things sort
of thinking about how friendships work
in the ancestral world is they're
they're very goal-oriented right there
this sort of affiliation motive is
it can be designed it can be based on
sort of
not quite altruism but like kin care and
like
care of people around you like sharing
food but it can also be based on teaming
up to
either you know like take down a mammoth
is sort of the the classic idea and so
um
that is the thing that
you know in modern days we have a lot of
competitive
um
activities and some of those are sort of
team based right sports right if you're
playing sports you are still with your
team against the other team but uh
one of the things we sort of discuss a
lot is this idea that
working together working together is a
good way
of matching that that's what our
ancestors used to do right it's like
instead of getting together to play
board games
you get together to
to build a hut and so or to fish
yeah
yeah
and so that i think is something that we
i get you know it's kind of fun writing
this book because it's like you'd think
a lot of this stuff would come
automatically right but uh
i don't think it did because our
ancestors didn't need to think about it
okay they would wake up in the morning
and that their you know cousins would
say we're going fishing today and you're
coming you know
and that doesn't happen so in in the
modern world i think sometimes when we
think about making friends we think all
i have to do is just go talk to people
and then i'll you know but in reality
i think we do have to do something
significant with them you know like it's
much easier to maintain friendships when
you have common
goals to accomplish and
yeah and and we're skipping the big the
biggest difference in recent modern
times which is
these days friendships are often virtual
right um which was obviously never the
case and and there's
data showing that spending more time
online like actually makes people less
happy versus spending time in person so
so one of the most simple things is just
you need to be hanging out with real
people in real life so
i certainly think that for men
uh bonding through shared efforts seems
to deepen friendships in a pretty
profound way i had a guy called max
dickens who's just written a book called
billy no mates about why men have a
difficulty with friendships at the
moment and
he he seemed to come across the same
the same conclusion which is that women
are really good at maintaining
friendships over time
men's friendships peak around about 18
the maximum amount of time that they
spend socially and then that just gets
fritted away and fritted away and one of
the reasons is that men need to see
other men
making effort not only for them but with
them you know they need to be
contributing and that kind of makes
sense like think about what the
friendships would be ancestrally the men
would go out they would hunt they would
do something hard together they would
bond over the fact that they were doing
that hard thing together but they
wouldn't get quite as attached as a
woman would to her friends because that
guy that you're out hunting with might
get killed you're out on a hunt it's
pretty likely that they're gonna it's
certainly more likely that they're gonna
die than one of the other mothers that's
back in the cave so i think it's called
it's aloe parenting where you kind of do
shared uh shared
of children and stuff like that
yeah i think even on top of the guys
dying there are other
aspects of female friendship they're
sort of like an information economy you
know that like in female friendships
where
knowing somebody they can help you they
can help you assess
potential mates right they can help you
raise kids as you're saying and so i
think it could also be partly for guys
the skill set to get somebody to come
and help you right if you see a guy who
can throw a spear and you're like hey
you can throw a spear i can throw a rock
let's go hunt a thing whereas
if you want somebody to say hey can i
trust you to tell me who else i can
trust around here knowing them for a
long time
really adds value to that so
what about uh dominance you looked at
the difference between dominance and
prestige when it refers to being
effective at getting ahead and becoming
statusful in life what did you learn
there
well so
people like prestigious leaders right
dominant leaders are
they're appealing like if you're
thinking about going to war um but if
you're thinking about
just working together as a group people
prefer
prestigious leaders people also often
when they conceptualize their ideal boss
will prefer a female leader um and so
it really depends on the situation at
hand but often
if you're talking about
getting along or a thing where resources
are going to be shared a workplace
environment things like that
prestige you know which is the idea that
they can teach you skills and
help guide you is
pretty key yeah let me let me just
expand on what you just said they've
let's define those terms a prestige
leader is someone who as dave just said
it's somebody uh there was a a paper by
joe hendrick and uh francisco gil white
that made this distinction and said that
um as far as they could tell at least
among chimpanzees
uh and most other mammals
uh leader the
the top of the status hierarchy is
occupied by an aggressive competitive
individual who you won't mess with you
don't want to go near them because
they'll bite your you know they'll bite
your head off you know um and
uh
we do have that we have that kind of you
know dot the tough schoolyard bully type
of thing in
human beings as well and that individual
if they want to take something from you
you know they're in a better position to
do it if they're the big tough bully um
and
uh a lot of times for a long time people
would read
evolutionary literature like chimpanzee
politics uh there was the head of the um
newt gingrich used to give it to
incoming republican uh
representatives and say this is the way
it is man it's all about blood you know
and you know take what you can don't
give don't don't give in bond together
to kick ass on anybody who gets in your
way
uh and that's one view of things um it
may be why the american congress doesn't
do so well you know getting anything
done um but another
another thing that's unique to humans is
that we
share information with one another
and so a prestigious leader is someone
who is is given status
because we want them to be in the
decision-making we want them to be at
you know driving the car because they've
got the skills uh and you get prestige
if you deliver goods and if you can
train other people and so that's that
just to kind of clarify that distinction
um and so as dave was saying the
research evidence suggests that we we do
like the bullies as leaders if we're
about to go to war and that's uh
mark von bucht did a lot of that
research at uh he's at
the v
free university in amsterdam
but
we've done a lot of research here and uh
a number of people who like uh henrik's
colleagues and john maynard have done
research suggesting that uh that we
really do like prestigious leaders you
know uh if if i'm gonna work for you
if you're gonna be my boss i don't want
you to be the big bully okay i want you
to be somebody i can get close to who
can you know
take me and show me the ropes and how to
get things accomplished and can lead me
in a you know lead me in a direction
i'll trust
so our preference for leaders responds
to the local demands of whatever
situation or ecology or environment
we're in
yeah and most of the time in the modern
world we're not at war
and if you're running a corporation i
think it's probably better not to think
of yourself as you know a dominant alpha
male chimp
but to think of yourself as a
prestigious human being
who was that guy that ended up in a ton
of different marriages giovanni
yes
yes so and this was this was before
dating apps right but he just would do
this he had a car and so he would go
from town to town um and
he met women at things like antique
shows and would sort of
get them to fall in love with him and
also get them to
lend or give him their
their assets their car their
you know their bank accounts and
went around
and did this to over a hundred women
was married to them i think and was yeah
like and stealing their stuff oh so
right this was the ultimate sort of like
machiavellian dating strategy right um
so which could not have happened in the
ancestral environment because you would
have had some brothers come hunting you
down and killing you uh but he was able
to drive to another state and uh start
again
how much evolutionary evidence do you
think there is for humans feeling
love and thinking about love in the way
that we conceive it now in the modern
world
so there the myth in
my field of psychology used to be well
in the social sciences used to be that
love was something that was invented in
the middle ages uh and you know it's
like about romantic love and chivalry
and so forth and those and before that
love didn't exist
that turns out to be bs there's a an
anthropologist uh jankoviak and fisher
they did a study where they actually did
a meta-analysis sort of a thing where
they got a whole they looked at all the
societies they could find and look they
were anthropology looked at the
anthropological reports and looked at
are there ever powerful bonds
between you know romantic partners in
this society and what they found is that
and i'm going to make this number up but
in the same 120 that they could look at
they found that the answer was
definitely yes and 110 of them and we
don't really know in the other 10 and so
they guessed
that powerful bonds are something that
happened even in hunter-gatherers uh and
so they're
we i would argue that they are part of
human nature the
bond between you know between lovers
what's the difference between strong
pair bonding and love
and is it just a semantic difference
that's what i mean yeah that's what i
would say yeah
i agree it's those that's just the words
we're using yeah i mean i think love is
a sort of common term that we use
that is
primarily used for sort of pair bonding
and then also sort of parental familial
love
um
[Music]
but yeah
there is that distinction yeah
no i'm actually just agreeing with you
dave that there is there's actually
studies that have been done where they
ask people uh to think of someone you're
in love with and they do think of people
in two categories
they think of romantic partners
and for that kind of love they talk
about feeling passion
and arousal and longing
and then they talk about familial love
or you know affiliate of love and then
there they just talk about bonding and
being close so there are two
those are two different
ways we use the word love but i think
what you're referring to chris was
romantic love it's that passion
it also it also sometimes i think is
used to refer to that sort of initial
feeling of euphoria at a sort of early
stage
of a relationship oh and so
which whereas pair bonding includes that
but also includes
the sort of
longer term
although yeah i remember magic i i
remember
hearing uh jonathan height talk about
passionate love and companionate love as
being
a
like a life cycle that you go through
well yes romantic relationships do shift
to those companionate relationships so
we have we have the companionate love
with our family members where we never
felt any passion for them okay
but uh romantic rome as dave just
pointed out romance tends to peak at the
beginning of a a relationship and you
really wouldn't want to go on for years
with this pounding of heart and sweating
palms and anticipation every time you
see
you know your wife okay because it you
die of a heart attack you know
and so turns out that in fact it does go
away and gets replaced with that more
kind of familial you know what you might
call brotherly love you know just this
is a person who's my mate in the sense
that you used the term before as a a
friend doug did you do some work on the
relationship between dominance and
attraction at some point
yes many many years ago uh it was one of
the uh one of the first uh
studies that was published in our major
journal the journal of personality and
social psych from an evolutionary
perspective it took us 10 years to get
it published because people didn't like
the idea of comparing us to other
animals
uh with ed sadala
did some research where we actually just
we had been
you know ed had been reading
sociobiology and i'd been reading a book
by jane lancaster called primate
behavior in the emergence of human
culture we thought well let's start to
apply this to humans and so
we did some what we now seeing very
simple studies where we showed people
potential partners who were either
dominant in the sense of they'd go into
an office they'd sit up right they'd
lean in towards the person in the desk
or they'd sit meekly over in the corner
and we did a number of ways we had
sometimes we had a psychologist
described you as dominant uh
and
uh what we found in all of those studies
is that
for women judging men they judge the guy
as sexier when he was dominant not when
he was domineering incidentally not when
he was pushy and aggressive you know and
nasty kind of dominant but when he was
confident
and you know that kind of dominant you
know uh
men didn't care one way or the other
uh was she they asked the question of
was she attractive
[Laughter]
do you know i don't know if you know the
study by john marshall townsend i think
his name is he
uh
he did a study where he brought people
into the lab and showed them
uh potential i think maybe it was like a
simulated dating study and i'm not
exactly sure the context but you would
look at a photograph
of if you're a man you would look at a
picture of a woman who either looked
gorgeous
uh or who looked average and she was
either wearing uh a burger king server's
outfit okay or she was wearing a you
know dress to the nines wall street you
know
fancy suit and you know rolex watch uh
the female kind or the guy same thing
you'd see a guy and he either looked
like a movie star
uh
or he looked like a dorky guy
but he'd be dressed
for wall street or for the burger king
server
and it turns out that the um when
when people were asked would you want to
date this person uh or have uh you know
amorous relationships with this person
uh
for women it mattered they would
actually prefer to date the dorky
looking guy in the wall street
clothes to the handsome guy who was
working at burger king for men
they didn't care what you know if she
was good
they'd prefer the good-looking woman who
worked for burger king to the
less attractive woman who was dressed to
the nines something else that i learned
in seth's book was about the difference
in mate value and perceived mate value
of men by women
based on the amount of money that they
earned
related to the job and the type of job
that they had
and what a lot of the time men say that
because women are hypergamous and
they're resource-seeking creatures that
it's hard because i need to climb up the
corporate ladder and i need to get
myself to 160 000 a year before anyone
is going to look at me and the data
doesn't seem to suggest that what it
suggests is that you can actually pivot
from one career into another career and
that women value a cooler job a lot more
than they value a high paying job in
fact they found that a man who works in
hospitality and was being paid 200 000 a
year would be equally attractive as a
fireman who was getting paid fifty
thousand dollars a year
wow
oh
so
that's interesting well the firemen
still that's a protective sort of job
right that's a
that and whereas i guess hospitality
it's
it's still there's a way in which it's
like you're you're
helping other people
so
for one reason or another it's just not
seen as state as full
yeah so huh i always remember this
example i think it's in robert wright's
uh the moral animal which is what like
30 years old now or something yes it is
still spectacular and um
he was talking about why do women fall
in love with the starving artist you
know the guitar singer that plays
acoustic sets on the night but sleeps on
his friend's couch and his justification
for that was that it's basically
buying a penny stock that it's a future
projection of potential mate value over
time
and i think that you know if you were to
look at the firemen
and the value not in terms of monetary
outcome but in terms of status over time
you would think right that guy is
probably going to accumulate a ton of
good will
everyone's going to be really altruistic
toward him you know if he saves a cat
from a burning building that's the
people are going to owe him whereas the
hospitality industry that being said
lawyer was the highest rated in terms of
category and i don't think that many
people see lawyers as being
super altruistic uh creatures either but
dominant right they
they will fight so that could be part of
it um
and so there's that
because both of those
have the this person has the ability to
protect me which i think is a
you know an attractive
legally and from a fire those are the
two ways that women primarily need
the rock
rock star
why the why the local rock star because
uh
you know jeffrey miller would argue he
had he wrote a beautiful book called the
mating mic
i was with jeffrey and diana last night
oh were you okay great um so
you know about the mating mind then and
what he would argue there is that in
some sense if i can show off my you know
my brilliant mind
uh
it indicates that i have good genes so
even if i don't currently have resources
uh if you mate with me your kids will be
peacocks too
your kids will be the human the human
version of a peacock is someone who can
speak eloquently uh or who can play the
guitar and you know try he'll be able to
charm women even though he doesn't have
money in the next generation i'd be
curious if they ever look to see how
much
more or less attractive a guy is
with a guitar versus being in a band
like does the actual
the the ability to sort of put together
a band and work as a group
seems like it would add an extra level
well yeah maybe but maybe it dilutes
down where the success is coming from
perhaps it's less to do with you and
perhaps it's more to do with i don't
know sort of machiavellian
uh
i don't know coordination and stuff like
that because by that virtue maybe the
guy that's the agent of the band or the
manager of the band should be the one
that's the most important because he's
the guy that puts them all together and
yet he's not
so yeah yeah i would be but you don't
see him doing that right like when you
see the bet i'd be really curious to see
whether a single guy like a guy up there
with a guitar by himself how he does
compared to a guy with a band um and and
i would bet on the guy with the band
actually
dave yeah you could probably talk a
couple of the graduate students
why is it that human females go through
menopause because i don't think that
many other animals or most other animals
do
hardly any hardly any of those i heard
of one uh one cetacean some in other
words some sort of a dolphin uh goes
through menopause that's the only other
species i've ever heard of
the the theory is
that
uh at some point a woman reaches a an
age
that humans over time began to become
more and more long-lived and
uh at a certain age
it's more danger if a woman if we live
in social groups we take care of the
members of our group uh and if the
mother is taking care of her children
and then her grandchildren
her bearing another child
there's the danger she'll die in
childbirth uh or that she'll die when
that child is young and so
it actually it's a an economic
sense that our genes making an economic
like you know like dawkins talked about
in the selfish gene it isn't like that
our genes actually make decisions but we
can think of them as saying click now
let's switch to this strategy
where i it's better off me being a
grandmother than
dying in childbirth or dying while i
have a very young child and so better to
just invest i think i think the reason
that it's sort of unique to humans comes
from
because of our brains pregnancy is
particularly dangerous for
moms right like
labor labor is dangerous um and
also we just need a lot of
like
or we benefit a lot from long-term
social support um more so than most
other animals so back
uh we've talked about this i think dave
but kim hill also did some data where
they actually
you know kim hill and hillary hillet
hillary kaplan a number of people have
have analyzed things like the calories
that are brought in by people over their
lifespan in these kind of horticultural
you know groups living
sort of close to the ancestral
circumstances living in the jungles of
south america and they
one of the things that they tell me
is that uh first of all the average
couple
uh doesn't really bring in enough
calories to care for themselves and
their children they're so busy taking
care of the kid they can't bring enough
calories and so they need their
relatives to help them out and their
neighbors to help them out and the
average male doesn't bring in enough
calories until he's like 20 years old to
really to be a guaranteed source of
protein
and so because we're so incredibly
dependent in ways that most other
animals were so incredibly dependent
on that risk pool group
that you know that that's what makes us
the special species in which it pays for
the female to
to stop reproducing because she's still
in this group she's still caring for
she's still sharing calories and
time and resources
on the uh on her you know second
generation offspring but she's no longer
continuing to produce more mouths that
need feeding right exactly right
and and she's yeah and she's no longer
she's not taking the risk because
if a woman has a kid
three years before menopause
right and she would have died
three years later that that young
three-year-old is going to be
essentially helpless right so
right so those younger kids especially
espec the more recent the kid was born
compared to
menopause if if there was a risk of
death
the better
right
does this mean that uh menopause
would have only
emerged
after a time when
human females were
growing up to be on average older than
40 years old or 45 years old or
something like that would have to but
there would have to have been selection
pressure operating at that age for it to
because it's a universal feature of
humans so there would have had to have
been some
selection pressure i guess one other
theory is there could have been a weird
bottleneck where there was only a small
number of human beings and there was a
genetic switch
and one of the females that the only one
that survived that'd be the other
possible theory and it was an accident
ah oh
that is cool but i guess that that could
potentially explain a whole bunch of
phenomenon that we can't really come up
with an explanation for that there's
adaptive explanations that are sometimes
contested wasn't there it was it was a
period that we got to where there was
less than 10 000 homo sapiens on the
planet right and everybody was in
indonesia or something
i don't know that but that
that uh that's interesting if that were
true it would have led to a lot of
bottlenecking and some we might have
some unique characteristics that we
don't really have to have
i mean it's also possible i don't i
don't know the
like anthropological literature on this
but it's possible that
they say it was a mutation that
worked in a small group and then it just
sort of
lived among humans until we got to the
point where
by and large
women tend to
live
past 40 then
it suddenly becomes incredibly
advantageous and then that's when it
spreads right yes that's that's when it
sort of becomes
that's a good point that's the way it
works
if it had a cost
you know then it would have been
selected out at some point but if it
actually had an advantage
you know that advantage could have
could have
been magnified it's like a latent
benefit almost that sort of sat
idling away and then becomes
significantly more beneficial at some
point and it it's the um
the
fortunate timing of both of those things
coming together that you have the
genetic mutation perhaps at a time when
there's an explosion of that genetic
mutation being advantageous but i
suppose that's what all mutations are
that's the name of the game random
variation and selective retention that
is evolution yeah i i mean it also but
it's it's kind of
wild to think that
that still happens you know what i mean
like that these sorts of things i think
even as we've been discussing this book
of like our evolved brains like i think
it's almost it's easy to imagine oh back
in the day everyone had our current
brains and those current brains were
perfectly matched and it turns out well
that wasn't true because there were
other people whose brains were not
matched to then and they died off
and then even now
there's so many different
variations on sort of human genes out
there you know that there are different
things that could
in a relatively short number of
generations become very
advantageous so what was that
what was that story about the guys who
had
brothers that were on the fbi's most
wanted list
ah yes
sure sure
whitey bulger right uh and his brother
and then the unabomber uh so we talk
about this these sort of two stories of
brothers with uh a very similar choice
and do you want to tell us a little bit
about that so sure the
so
uh whitey bulger was on the fbi's 10
most wanted list but his brother was the
uh he was the president
of the university of massachusetts and
he was also the president of he was a
lawyer law professor so he was the
president of the
of the massachusetts state senate for
some period of time or the state
represent house of representatives i
forget which that's a very prestigious
very successful guy and his brother was
a very successful mobster in boston
killing people uh and
uh
the question came when the fbi they went
to whitey and said do you know where
your brother is and he did but he
refused to speak to them uh
he lost his job because of it you know
and it took 20 years for them to find
his brother
and the other one is
david kaczynski who was a guy who
studied english and was a you know uh
i don't know if he ever uh what he did
for a living was a teacher or something
but uh he um
he had a brother who was just brilliant
okay uh
ted kaczynski ted kaczynski was a
professor
uh at berkeley which was you know in the
us one of the most prestigious universes
probably in the world one of the most
prestigious universities but he kind of
cracked up and he went to live in
montana i just drove through by there
the other day it's really beautiful
where he was where he chose to live
in lincoln montana but he
uh
he became he started sending bombs to
people who we thought were destroying
nature you know um
and
uh his brother turned them in right and
so this was i think this i really like
this dilemma and these two stories of
these because these are two
if you think about the each of these
guys brothers right they're in a similar
situation of you're sort of trying to
live
a law abiding life and you
assuming they both knew i mean i know
with ted kaczynski there was a point
where uh david's wife was like dude i
feel like these letters are written like
they were written by your brother right
and he's like trying to figure it out so
no no he wanted to deny it no no that's
not my brother and he said yeah you know
and then she found some exact passage
and so
then he went and showed it to the fbi
yeah but it's a really interesting
question of of trade-offs right this
trade-off between sort of getting along
with society and
kin care right of sort of
protecting your family um and
the question is dave what would you do
if you found out that i was
unabomber
i mean so how would you go well the
answer i think i'd sort of i mean i hate
to be like yeah i would go the
the whitey bulger route you know like
but there is there is a sort of feeling
of like oh do you work it out
internally right do you keep is it is it
as a family
do you keep your family in check
rather than turning to the outside world
oh yeah
you have a debt to society another
interesting case of where uh our genetic
interests are
one thing and then there's our
obligations to society which isn't
completely independent of our genetic
interest because if we
you know if our brother was discovered
to be a murderer it would hurt our
social standing too so it isn't like
they're completely it doesn't like genes
versus culture
but you know in both cases there's a
decision to be made what's the best
what's in your best interest and what's
in the best interest of the rest of
society
and i think it's a fun question of why
did the unabomber's brother
turn him in
but why whitey bulger's brother didn't
turn him in what do you guess on that
dave well part of it might be they
didn't live in the same place right um
the like ted and david kaczynski when
people move away
those sort of
that feeling of being part of the same
tribe
gets harder to maintain
and so uh which is one of the things we
actually discuss not
not
just so that
your family doesn't turn you in for
crimes but we do sort of talk about
there's a lot of benefits to
staying geographically close to
your family and so and i think that that
a lot of that comes down to
you guys help each other out right when
when they're nearby so um
i wonder as well whether the fact that
in the modern world
status is probably held in high regard
but any of the
actual physical fallout and consequences
of your brother being the unabomber or
whatever are less so previously you said
that there's this sort of cohesion
between genetic interest and
environmental interest or community
interest but let's say that your brother
was a dangerous murdering psychopath he
if you're in a group of 150 people he
may threaten one of your children he may
threaten your your wife or one of your
brothers in law or something like that
that is no longer that sort of fallout
is no longer a concern but the statusful
side of things is potentially even more
of a concern because that is one of the
commodities that we're playing about
with now
yeah although although i think a lot of
times people who are
aggressive in nature are still less
likely to be aggressive
or at least murderous to biological
relatives so
it actually may be that if you have a
murderous sibling
you
whose lives nearby you reap the benefits
sort of as we're going back to this idea
of sort of having a
a dominant person on your team there may
be some advantages to having an
aggressive person is there not a
potential risk here that
most murders of partners are committed
by the first place that they look is the
spouse i wonder whether
you would be safe but you're immediate
non-biological to them but biological to
you
uh
genetic relatives maybe yeah no again
back to martin daley and margo wilson
who i mentioned before they wrote a book
called homicide and one of the the
counter
people always used to say oh well if if
genes are the thing why is it that
people always kill their relatives and
what it turns out is that they don't
kill their relatives they kill their
spouses okay um
uh and they kill people who they live
with who are not related to them but
they hard even though their relatives
pissed them off
more than anybody else you know we're
doing some research now which which
indicates that people are more likely to
get hit and even hurt by their brothers
and sisters as they're growing up
but they don't kill one another they
almost nev despite the opportunities and
despite the annoyances
killings between siblings are
so rare
as to be you know an anomaly when they
do what what about what about like
in-laws are
because i know killings between step
parents and kids are less rare right but
i've never i've never actually heard
this question of do people kill their
brother-in-law or not yeah i don't know
that's a good i bet you martin daley
knows the answer my prediction is yes
that's that's a dangerous position to be
in if you're in a if you're in a house
if a child's in a house with a parent
that is non-biological there's a hundred
times risk that that child is going to
be is going to be killed and i think
that that shows just how hard it is to
raise a kid and the fact of the matter
is that a lot of the reason that you put
up with raising them is because they're
yours
exactly right
so rounding all of this out you guys
come up with an evolutionary
justification for being kind which uh
given some of the areas that we've gone
into today might seem
averse to
part of our nature
what give me the evolutionary
justification for being kind
well i think the justification is that
it will help you
solve your it will help you meet your
evolved needs in the modern world oh
right and so and one of the ways that i
think that we're immediately mismatched
is often
our selfish desires ring really loudly
right in our heads um and we don't
really necessarily need people out there
saying oh you should really
look out for yourself right like we'll
generally do that um
but
there are a lot of ways that by helping
other people meet these needs um
[Music]
you really benefit and this is a thing
that was true in the ancestral kingdom
you know we've talked about this with
status you know one of the things i
think people see all the time these days
is
status is how
big your boat and your house are but
really those are
signs of status that generally in a in a
system that works those will come from
your contributions to the group right
and that is what even when you think
about animal kingdoms when we've talked
about like a dominant
like
ape or something they still can
contribute they still can protect the
other members of the group they can
still you know
and so
by thinking about how you can help the
other members of
your group
and the people around you achieve their
fundamental motives
that turns out to be a really good way
to achieve yours right i mean we're not
saying to be totally unselfish that's an
important in fact i was just
re-listening to the book the selfish
gene and one of the things and uh
dawkins had a 25th anniversary edition
in which he defended himself and said
you know i didn't say that selfish genes
produce selfish people selfishness
itself
uh is not a good thing in a whole human
being it's but it's it's there in our
genes but our genes may instruct us to
be cooperative in order to promote their
survival okay and in fact if you're
living in a social group
the you know
that there's reasons to
be nice to other people uh and it's
sometimes it is hard actually
the reason part of the reason we put
that in there is that about when dave's
younger brother uh was 10 years old i
asked a bunch of my colleagues some of
whom are you know famous biologists and
positive psychologists and i asked them
if you had one piece of advice for a 10
year old
kid what would it be and none of them
said even though they're biologists they
know the theory of evolution they didn't
say go out and you know conquer you know
and do the best for your genes
find them feel them and forget them and
i'll skip the third f in there you know
ah and none of them said that all of
these people who were very successful
uh they said
most commonly be nice to other people
yeah and my colleague mark schaller said
it best he said look
you know being nice to other people is
actually in some level being nice to
yourself because if you're nice to other
people they'll trust you
uh they'll be your friends they'll give
you things and so
in some sense it's the best way to be
nice to yourself so so i do i do want to
just sort of qualify one last thing
because we keep using the word nice
and i think throughout the book because
there's ways that you can be nice that
allow you to be taken advantage of right
um and i actually think the word that i
would use
instead of nice is helpful right like if
you if you find ways to be
so it's not always like you don't want
to agree
with every
bad idea somebody suggests to you
because that's a way you could be nice
that's not necessarily going to
going to help you or help them but
consciously thinking about how to be
sort of useful
to your friends useful to your
co-workers useful to
your partners useful to your family
that i think is the key
doug and dave ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out the work that
you do and keep up to date with stuff
where should they go
that's it check out the book read the
book and i would say based upon what
they just said buy a copy of the book
for your uh
for your sons or your fathers or your
brothers or your mothers
so
oh
yeah i think that i think that's
that would be great we and we would
appreciate people by and it's solving
problems with the stone age brain
solving modern problems with the stone
age brain so gentlemen i appreciate you
thank you for today good talking to you
thank you what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]